[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits I'm link and I'm
Rhett this week at the round table of
dim lighting we're gonna be catching up
with one another about some recent solo
outings that we had some solo weekend's
huh we've been holding on to these
stories for as we do like for a number
of days oh yeah
and so we're gonna we're gonna I'm gonna
share my experience of going out into a
weird place in the California badlands
bad land out in the desert with just me
I wasn't alone cuz it took Jade but I
was you did I was to know that I did not
take any of my human companions family
members or friends and then you're gonna
give me the story of you going into
where that what Badlands did you go in I
went to the good lands I went to the
Central Coast of California so maybe
there's some contrast in our story yeah
and I think there may be I didn't take
my dog he didn't my dog's a little bit
more of a handful but anyway we had some
experiences there I we don't know any
details of what happened to one another
but we know the place the places that we
went the kinds of things that we did
right I actually had to make myself
notes of this one thing that happened to
me because when it happened to me it was
so ridiculous I was like I have to
immediately write this down so I wrote
it down and then I just went back
through what I wrote down and made notes
for myself so I can give you the details
of what happened to me okay that's the
kind of thing we've got in store yeah I
and I just a teaser for me I feel like
there there were more than one point
when did that sentence that wasn't
grammatically you would say there was
more than one point there were more than
one point points there were multiple
points in my experience where I said out
loud in biscuits too for no one to hear
what I'm just gonna say that's a that's
a question that you want to be asking
yourself quite a bit because the sign of
things that you're doing something right
you know and we decided to go on not to
go on a trip together so we'd have some
to talk about Anspach yes no that's not
that's not really the case I mean it's
so hard to have an opportunity we've
never have an opportunity for solo
excursions but because our plan I'm
gonna tell him so what I just I mean our
plan our planned trip to go to India it
didn't work out you know just full
disclosure we were going to travel to
India and do a week's worth of shows to
wrap up the season a good mythical
morning and the logistics didn't work
out I mean it just didn't it just didn't
work out you got to get certain
paperwork in a certain amount of time
and it just didn't come together and we
were very bummed but so it that was
gonna be like a week and a half trip
there wasn't our fault though I do want
to say oh yeah yeah it wasn't our fault
we basically it really wasn't anybody's
physically weren't let in the country to
do what we wanted to do we didn't get to
we didn't get the visa that you need to
go and make videos in India we didn't
get rejected it just we never heard back
right in the amount of time that we
needed it in order to do it we were
trying to do it all in the right way you
know as opposed to just going over there
and just starting filming so we do still
have a dream of going somewhere outside
of the United States in order to produce
a show on the road you know produce it
like a week's worth of good mythical
morning I mean it was I I did not
anticipate how disappointed I was gonna
feel when we knew that it wasn't gonna
happen cuz it was gonna be a big
surprise for you know all the mythical
beasts and now it's just something that
that's just something you said I hope
you're okay with saying it but I'm fine
with it it's just it's just all negative
it's just a disappointment to bring it
up makes me want to cry a little bit but
we'll go somewhere but you know what we
have the intention to travel with the
show at some point and everything was
kind of lighting up and then it fell
through and because we were going to be
gone we you know Kristi and Jesse
planned a weekend away and then with a
we had childcare arranged for all of our
kids so
but I've been planning then we were left
with this weekend that like when we were
gonna be in India now it's like well my
kids are gonna be at home but there's
childcare so that means I gotta get out
it I gotta take advantage it was it was
more calculated on my part cuz I've
actually been planning a solo trip and
I'm playing another week-long solo trip
probably during the summer just well
just heads up just tell me when that
week is I don't I mean I want in
maybe not week long but we'll talk about
what happened to us and then we'll
decide whether or not that's a good idea
you need to do it again yeah but before
we get into that I just feel like I have
to briefly address something you know
first of all shout out to red MC on
Twitter if you follow me on Twitter you
already know this that I have begun to
tweet about fortnight yes I've become
that guy you can hate me if you want
line up I think it's actually get in
line is what you're supposed to say like
you're like is that what you're your
tweet that's what you're tweeting about
only no so let me give you a little
background on this of course my kids
play for tonight because their children
in America and are just children in the
world in 2018 right so they have an Xbox
or a PC or whatever you can play it on
and they play it that makes you feel
better about your your kids a dick and
the fortnight and that you can say it
that way
my son Lincoln is also plays more as I
guarantee he's played more games than my
son yeah he's he's better yeah I'm sure
he is
I'm sure he's better than me too so he's
pretty obsessed um I did I'm not I'm not
a gamer I've never really been a gamer
the only system that I ever owned was
the the the very first Nintendo system
in Sega at the same time that was a
great great year and but I fell off of
the whole gaming thing and then I'm done
like I've talked about on the show I've
done a little bit of mobile gaming but I
see the kids and they're doing the
first-person shooter games and they
they're the way the controller is
happening and they're aiming and every
time I've tried to step into the
situation I feel like someone stepping
in like all of a sudden so you you play
yeah I'm like on a ballet stay
and I have got no training and I'm just
an idiot and a leotard look at that
guy's bulge you know just really just
embarrassing situation that's how I feel
when I'm playing these games exposed and
I'm horrible at him I die instantly I
did a little bit of that Star Wars game
when it came out which is awesome
Battlefront and I got killed so much and
I hated myself for playing it but then
fortnight rolls around everybody's
talking about it Drake is playing it
yeah you know and I'm like I just feel
like I am at a tipping point maybe the
tipping point is I'm at a decision point
in my life as a 40 year old man where I
can make a decision to shut it down and
just say I am NOT going to be part like
as you get older you see society moving
forward and they're adapting and they're
enjoying things and they're doing things
and then at some point you get to an age
where you're like that is not going to
be for me like I'm checking out of that
I'm not going to be into that type of
music I'm not going to seek to
understand that type of clothing you
begin checking out and my theory is I as
you begin you're already slowly dying
basically right after you're born but
you begin to accelerate the process of
dying the more you begin checking out
from the things that youth are doing in
the brain that's my theory
yeah it's always like I have to figure
out how to play this game in a way that
could be somewhat enjoyable as opposed
to just sitting there dying over and
over again but in my quest to somehow
that's what happened you played the game
and you just died repeatedly like that
Tom Cruise movie without killing anyone
I'm sorry that Emily Blunt movie without
killing anyone because dying is kind of
the point of fortnight unless you're the
last person to win which that will
probably never happen to me but the
thing is is that most people who die all
the time are also killing other people
all the time and I'm not I'm just dying
over and over and over and over and over
and over and over and again and so I had
died like 25 30 times in a row and just
thought there was no hope I thought you
just had to build a fort before the
storm hit like those are the things that
I understand I know that there shoot
involved but that's just when people are
trying to tear down your fort before the
storm hits the storm is an ingenious
tactic
I was joking hon I know what it is to
get you to fight Lincoln that's that's
the only way I can connect with my son
is to talk about his fort nightclub well
you should talk about it in a way that
makes sense with the youth I was making
a joke I didn't understand what was
funny about it
yeah okay so I am in the midst of dying
multiple times and then I'm like I'm
gonna tweet about this I don't tweet a
lot but I was like I think I got a tweet
that might be you know it's some
relevancy I'm gonna hashtag fortnight
I'm gonna be that guy oh you did
hashtag fortnight and I tweeted how many
times you have to die in hashtag
fortnight before you're actually dead
inside ooh pretty good tweet you know
gives the joke I made earlier you didn't
get right and I I tweet that and then
the very next day I I'm back on I'm back
on Twitter and I had learned about this
ninja guy the ninja his name isn't his
his gamertag is ninja and he's like the
top of the gaming world you know he's
he's he's gaming it up with Drake and
famous DJs etc that's when I heard about
him and I mean this guy's huge right now
and so I might I see him pop up on
Twitter I'm like I know who that guy is
with the blue hair yeah yeah he's the
Beaufort 9 guy follow him oh he's got
blue hair too
yeah well he's done different things
with this here I I followed him I follow
him I finally went like 11:30 at night
you know after like after like a
fortnight session okay you were grinding
grinding on fortnight I did say by that
time I killed two people
oh 52 52 attempts killed two people
you're a murderer and he immediately
follows me back because you don't see on
the verified no he's got one of those
accounts where he just Auto follows you
back and then I go to his accountant
money he's got like almost two million
followers he's only following like 800
people I think this is a legit follow
and then I realized
that he has replied to my tweet before
tonight what directly to me so I'm like
Walker he says I can't remember what he
said exactly well just how old is this
guy by the way in his twenties he's
married but he's in his 20s okay he said
just not a child just one more time
and my answer to my tweet yeah cuz
that's the mentality what's your tag
what's your tag first of all I was like
what is my tag what does that mean that
was the first question that I had you
know that's how much of a new buy I hope
that wasn't your next week so I don't
remember what I said back to him but
something about I'm just I'm horrible
I'm worse at the game than newborn baby
I actually then tweeted my tag back to
him but then somebody was like DM next
time I was like oh DM right now delete
tweet took my tag off because I don't
know anything about what I'm doing I'm
again I'm like a man in a leotard just
walking around exposing himself yeah I
remember
and so I retweet it I tweet back at him
long story short big again I mean and I
had been in a DM Twitter conversation
with in the Ninja himself hey this is
the like this is like having a
conversation about basketball with
LeBron himself you know what I'm saying
this is the keys are the kinds of things
that are happening on the red MC Twitter
oh wow and I am I
I'm not gonna tell you what we talked
about okay I mean but I will say in one
sense it's not actually an exaggeration
the analogy you made because he's that
good at this game according to what
Lincoln tells me it's amazing the dude
is I mean he's he's a professional gamer
but it's almost an understatement in
terms of like it really is phenomenal to
watch it's like I've never watched let's
play videos and because I haven't played
any of the games but now when you play
the game Vinick I understand the
dynamics of the game it's just like you
play a little bit of basketball or you
play a little bit of golf and people are
like why do you enjoy watching golf well
because I've played a lot of golf and so
I can you know it looks like just some
lazy fat dudes walk
but the hitting balls around but when
you understand how difficult it is you
become you admire it and you want to
watch but what is the conversation the
DM conversation the DM conversation is
about some plans that we're making
what are just planning some things I
don't want to disclose that don't know
if the plans will come to fruition but
you know we're just yes my bud ninja and
I just talking on Twitter like we do
DMing that's what you do with your
friends on Twitter Thank You me plants
making plans however let me just say
you're involved in this because I also I
started having fortnight dreams and I
had a dream first of all weird stuff
started happening I there's a house
that's being constructed in my
neighborhood and it's just wood frames
right now and I saw it and I thought for
it it's like that's happen are the forts
in your brain is turning a kid mush yeah
I'm turning into a youth I believe I
found the Fountain of Youth
yeah you know I'm saying are you making
you smarter when you begin looking at
look at a house and it becomes a fort
the youth it's like it's like it's like
I've hooked up my boys building a fort
across the street dirt it's like our
house son I've hooked up an IV directly
to a teenager and I'm getting their
blood and it's coursing through my veins
it's causing some weird things to happen
but what's happening to the team the
teen is slowly dying I know and you
don't care because it's the first-person
shooter and you know what those but it
was your conscience you're in a fight
when one of my fortnight dreams oh yeah
something won't for reason for some
reason am i jumping around trying not to
get you know it wasn't in the game of
fortnight you jump yeah you look like
you kind of look a little stupid when
you do the jumping you're not jumping
because you're not in the game me and
you have assembled a large group of
people and we're doing a seminar okay
about fortnight and you're walking in
and the dream you walk in and the dream
of my you know I whispered to him like
just make something up and then we begin
mmm I don't remember the specifics of
what we said but yeah I can do that we
had a fortnight seminar so maybe that's
maybe that's what I'm on the road to you
know I
ninjas my best friend on Twitter was
DMing me constantly and constantly yeah
once he did it once but maybe you'll do
it again and then I'm playing as I as I
see fit as it into my schedule which is
not a lot but not incredibly busy right
now so I'm actually able to do a little
bit and then I'm having dreams about it
maybe we'll have a seminar you know I'm
hooked up to the youth I feel like I
kind of feel like a new man I could tell
something was different about you that
you've yeah kind of like a little flair
getting a little on my sweatshirt
pubescent hormonal awkwardness
you can always grind like you smell me
when I come in the room voice cracking
kind of a thing you smell like I've been
running yeah teens always smell like
they've been running facial features
kind of out of proportion yeah a little
bit of awkwardness gods it's in weird
places well in one sense my my journey
into solidarity was is in stark contrast
maybe both of ours to to being a
fortnight but in some ways it's maybe I
had some of the same feelings well I
can't wait to hear about it but let's
take a short break to remind everybody
that you can get the shirt that link is
wearing not the exact mythical best but
a shirt that is designed exactly like
that at mythical dot store this is this
is one of my favorite pieces of merch
that we three-quarter length sleeves he
got this called baseball because because
the baseball players they need 3/4
lengths but they need the forum to be
exposed I don't know why do you know the
theory I thought this is like rec
softball shirt I don't know that
professional is actually wear these but
if you don't like your sleeves this long
you want a shorter we got plenty of
those too but the reason you want your
elbows covered is for sliding headfirst
mythical dot store the place to equip
yourself with things you want thank you
for supporting intern attainment for all
types of stuff even Cologne I'm serious
we got that seriously okay link tell us
about your time
as with many things you mentioned you
were taking a solo trip and I didn't
know if my feeling should be hurt
because I'm like well okay so that's
that's the nice way of saying I'm not
invited
oh come on okay so then I'm like I gotta
come up with something but we had talked
you know we we dedicated a chapter of
the book to isolate yourself with
yourself yeah it's it's an aspect of
mythicality - is an opportunity to
rejuvenate potentially to reflect - you
might use the term recenter so my
feelings were not hurt it was I was like
yes you're exactly right
the this I can I can do anything I could
go anywhere and Reading Rainbow I'm
gonna do that and you know I thought
about your experience out in the desert
alone and I had not had one of those yet
mmm sounds like I was immediately
thinking this is your first weekend
alone my desert getting married my
desert solo experience it like going on
I can't read on a solo trip trip yeah
since that that's summer before I got
married when I went to Nashville but I
visit him a friend Josh a long time ago
but he worked during the day so during
the day I was so little right okay so
we're talking a long time ago oh yeah
1999 mm-hmm
so I was thinking about the desert and
then I'm like well I don't know that
after hearing your your story about the
tent camping thing and like you kind of
got freaked out and I mean you can read
about it in the book I'm like well maybe
maybe before I go total tent I'm gonna
search Airbnb okay you know and then
they have these things called
experiences it's not just about places
to stay now but they can give you stuff
to do with with like Sherpas guides type
situation and I thought maybe I won't
sign up for those but I'll use it as
like using the map as I can drive for a
road trip and come up with something to
do that's inspired by one of the
experiences even though I don't won't
sign up
and then lo and behold I started I went
to the map view and I started dragging
it East and like kind of towards Joshua
Tree got out towards where you went
mm-hmm I've been wanting to go back to
Joshua Tree
and then the map view was really wide
and there was nothing that popped up
except all of a sudden one Airbnb popped
up in the middle of nowhere and I zoomed
in and I was like whoa this was this is
past Joshua Tree this is past Palm
Springs
oh no that big body of water that's the
frickin Salton Sea and it's past that Oh
past that because we always always
wanted to visit the salt and sea because
it's like an abandoned getaway community
and that was part of my solo trip the
first time the Salton Sea oh you did go
there yeah I didn't remember that part
yeah on the way back I drove south
stayed at there for like a couple hours
okay
did you end up going there and then the
place that popped up when I zoomed in
was just past that and I when i zoom I
was like oh crap
it's Slab City right I've heard of this
place it's the type of thing that like
vice will send one of their journalists
out to the slab city and didn't we talk
about it on the episode of Jim and we
did yes it was it was like one of those
list episodes back when we used to
alternate telling like most isolated
places on earth or something yeah and it
was the history of slab city people tend
to write about it in a way and maybe I
don't remember how we talked about it on
the show honestly but I they tend to
like sensationalize it as a lawless
community that's totally off the grid
meaning off the electrical grid there
was places with no laws that was the
episode I don't know the title of it but
it was places that are subject to laws
which is not really true but claimed to
be true by them so I'm like hold on if
there's an Airbnb there amongst the slab
errs because what it is is it is a place
in the middle of the desert with no
electricity no running water it's
literally just a war war to
military base very small that was
abandoned by 1960-1961 they took
everything off but they left the
concrete slabs that they had poured to
build their like I'll just say barracks
just say it for lack of a better word
and then because I researched the
backstory in the sixties some some
people came in to harvest creosote which
i think is like I don't even know what
it is it's the stuff that you put on
light poles in order to preserve them
there's a natural thing that you get out
of there yeah so I thought was an oil
by-product and the people who were out
there getting it and whatever way they
were getting it started camping there on
these slabs and then some people just
ended up staying there permanently and
squatting on what was and is public land
so it's not technically legal but ever
since then there's been people who've
gone out there and just squatted just
lived yeah I mean you might be tempted
to say it's a homeless commune and but I
needed to find out for myself okay so
I'm starting reading the reviews and it
was like okay this is this is a super
host as certified by Airbnb maybe I can
fill start to feel a little bit of
comfort here in in renting out for 30
bucks there what appears to me to be
based on the pictures and abandoned in
Mobile RV okay this sounds great you
know me and RVs that is at that's honest
lab as lab city or I'm near slabs and it
turned out it was very near Slab City it
was not in the middle of like the slab
the slab errs community okay
it was across the street from a huge art
installation that alcohol that is called
Salvation Mountain yep I'm going to tell
you more about Salvation Mountain later
but tourists will come through they'll
see Salvation Mountain Oh take some
pictures and
front of this mountain which is crazy
and then they'll leave mm-hmm they want
they might drive through Slab City at a
rapid pace and then get out it's not a
tourist destination yeah now not
typically an Airbnb experience either
but I'm reading on the Airbnb and
they're like okay it's people are
leaving reviews and they're like cherry
is so nice she will make you a vegan
meal cherry cherry not Cherie but cherry
sherry and her husband she on top of I
don't know how to I said okay she was on
top of it yeah but according to the
reviews she's on top of things at it
that's what I'm in series on top of
things and oh you know sure she'll make
you coffee and breakfast I'm like okay
so I can go out here there's no there's
no there's you're off the grid but
somebody will make me breakfast is her
husband's name able oh I love it already
sherry enable yeah and he was very able
and so okay I'm like you know what I
think I'm gonna do this
and so I clicked I was like you know
what I would tend to walk away from my
phone at that point be like I'm gonna
think about this for another day and
then I'm gonna find all these reasons
not to go to slab city might you know
what I'm just gonna clicking I'm gonna
do it and then immediately like we were
having a conversation and she accepted
my request and boom I'm booked on the on
the edge of slab city across the street
from Salvation Mountain $30.00 you can
never get back you're in now oh yeah the
RV was painted red all over it like even
the tires which were like shredded it
was not you cannot drive this thing away
so then I I leave in the three-hour
drive ended up taking five hours
coachella man and yeah cuz it was the
same that was the second weekend at
Coachella and I I it definitely didn't
help the traffic so I'm I Drive past the
north side of the Salton Sea
which it is
that is just crazy because did you get
out did you stop not on the way in
because the Sun was setting and I wanted
to get to the RV before it got dark so I
so I'm that part of the state is like a
alien landscape it really is I mean the
Salton Sea is is is the biggest lake in
California and it's it was made by
accident like a water overflow from the
river and then the water is trapped in
such a way that like the salt content
was so high that it messed up the
ecosystem that like certain times a year
there's lots of fish that like just died
on the shore and where they thought it
would be this like waterskiing and like
boating community with Sonny Bono if
people just abandon it now there are
there are still people who live there
yeah which when I drove back through I
went on the beach Jade and I went on the
beach and then we drove through another
little town Bombay Beach where they have
power and running water that's good
which at that point in my trip was
revolutionary yeah after the two days
that I spent outside of slab city so
anyway I get to the RV it's just getting
to be dark and boy I just I wasn't
nervous I was just you know and then I
pull in what does your phone work out
here the phone does work okay wouldn't
you feel better it made me feel a lot
better and I did have one of those other
like Lily I took one of Lily's like
battery extender things like you can
charge that up and it just gives you a
second battery for your phone so again
between the Airbnb reviews and the
battery I felt a little bit better and
when I pull in I realize oh it's not
just one RV there's three here and as I
pull in there's two women just one of
them cheery um no and they're like
waving mean they're waving at me like
stop stop stop stop stop like don't
don't drive any further and I like and I
was like oh gosh I'm here and there's
people there's freaking villagers
already and so I stop it I'm like roll
down the window I'm like um hi and
they're like don't just don't drive any
further because the sand you might get
stuck stuck in the sand you
I think you're okay where you are and so
then I'm in a conversation so then I
start walking over there and one woman
had just arrived from Sweden and it met
this other woman in San Diego I think
and then they both found their way to to
this RV to be my neighbor so chary and
Abel rent three RVs yes smart why we're
it 1-1 you can rent three yeah they all
paint in different colors
yep red white and then off whitish oh
not much there that red white and blue
the other woman the other woman had a
had a sign hanging in front of her RV
that said psychic readings five dollars
in her on her RV on the the little fence
in front of it so she's been there for a
while turns out she had been there maybe
two weeks but I guess she carries the
sign wherever she goes yeah they're both
very friendly they were drinking wine
and eating steak I could smell the
campfire and there's like a party they
were very friendly and then I'm like
well and it got totally dark by the time
I was talking to him for 30 minutes and
then I'm like well I got to get over
here and then I finally get to the RV
and this there there's no step to get
into the RV but cherry and Abel are not
at the RV no I haven't met them yet they
just give you instructions only how to
get in it I texted her and I said I'm
here and she was to show up but she
wasn't there yet and then I I mean I
have some pictures I'll show you and for
the video version I guess we can throw
some of those up there but the step
leading into the RV was a milk crate
with a board almost twice as wide as the
milk crate strapped on top of the milk
crate and then printed on the sign
printed on the board and like black
paint and handwriting it says be careful
oh yeah I mean
and it you step too far to the left or
the right you're gonna take a tumble but
I couldn't help but wonder were they
also referring to my entire entire
experience but essentially and then it
says carefully above that yeah on the on
the oh it says careful and it has two
L's they misspelled it well that means
extra careful and then when you so then
I go in the RV I took some pictures
portraits of Jade well the next day
there was a moment of solitude I got a
little bored the only piece of artwork
inside of the RV was this detailed
eyeball bloodshot with blood tears
coming out of it and when you look
closely you realize oh great there's
also a hand crawling out from the bottom
eyelid yeah
that's not disturbing at all when it's
pitch-black and there's no light inside
of this RV which was basically just like
I said an abandoned RV that was it was
very well swept you know it's and there
was some bedding but no power no well
they did have an LED like a solar
charged LED light bulb that you could
turn on which actually made it freakier
so like and then I get in there I'm like
okay these people are nice next-door but
okay Jade we're in this together we
could just stay in this RV for the next
two days and not leave you know maybe
we'll be okay I stayed in the RV that
night and it got a little yeah a little
scary but then cherry and Abel drove up
in their car and they had they they had
food for me they were very friendly and
they said we're going into Slab City
tonight because there's there's some
musicians that are going to be
performing so yeah they do that they're
like oh there's a stage and then people
bring their own chairs I've seen this on
video and then so just people go up and
perform with like a solar power PA
system
once they started playing I could hear
it I couldn't see them but I could hear
the sound coming from around the bend
from in slabs video from my RV I ended
up not going that first night I was like
I'm gonna eat dinner and then you know
how I just didn't settled I was getting
settled you know I didn't feel like I
don't want to go into town in the dark I
did I'd rather rather see it in the
light first yeah first night yeah the
next morning I go to well Abel comes in
his car and he's like I will lead you to
my house and so I get in my car and I
follow him we're just driving off the
road into the desert just driving around
this is to get breakfast because they
provide that yeah we drive for about a
mile
like literally through the desert and
you'll see and you start to see what at
first - through the uneducated eye looks
like piles of trash like huge mounds of
garbage and then I was like oh we're
gonna drive right past this pile of
garbage and then we get closer and I
would realize this is somebody's
dwelling yeah
and it's in it's in it's Hollow trash
home it's pieced together in such a way
as to construct shelter and boundaries
and things on public land or they own
this land
public land yeah and so you realize it
it's not trash is reclaimed scrap that's
been used to build a home and that's
what cherry and Abel live in and then we
round another corner and I see like a
whole compound of like hodgepodge of
stuff like this one has a fence made out
of pallets of wood and a couple of
different structures one of which is two
stories tall and there's like a parking
area like with like rocks put down and
like you drive it to it and there's a
sign that says camp freedom and this is
their compound
then I go through the gate Jade now goes
through the gate I close the gate behind
me so she didn't run out into the desert
and never come back to me and Abel's
super friendly cheery super friendly
older these people and late 20s what
they're young okay I've not yes I was
fishing older people yeah they are very
tan people okay
like very sun-baked I don't know they
might you know she might have been well
she might have been mid-30s you know I
tend to think of myself as as like 28 so
I tend to age everybody else down so but
but not older definitely not older than
us but I didn't have a toupee because
you can't usually I definitely can't
spot that spot a toupee he didn't have a
to pick your - he's toupee blind and
then I meet their five children what
their five kids ranging in age from 13
to toddler well then I would have seen
they're not in their 20s yeah that's
what made me rethink that yeah but - but
they did start early yeah and the kids
were you know the younger kids were shy
kind of names are they but the older
kids I can't remember but it it wasn't
anything like Jerry and Abel Rock no
stilt no but that but the oldest the
oldest daughter was very you know very
nice and engaging she homeschools they
homeschooled in there when I walk into
like the what I'll call the corral that
is like their front yard there's they
have like a raised garden that they said
the wind blew it over and they were
trying to fix it and they're like
growing some stuff and they have to haul
in all their water and then there's
there's a two-story structure made out
of wooden pallets with them plywood put
over it they explain this to me I mean
cherry said hey we've got the only
two-story dwelling in Slab City they had
been there for many years like
four and crazy so and then in front of
the two-story structure was like a black
mesh that they repurposed as like a sun
block / flattened fly net what's it
called mosquito net type situation and
that was over a like queen sized bed
which was basically sitting in front of
the house so like their bedroom was just
covered in a net in front of where
everybody else lived and you know I
they had television because I heard it
and they have a generator they have they
have solar power solar power solar power
and then they she had taken and made
like a pony wall around the side and so
they had this like little courtyard area
made out of Adobe mud with like old
glass bottles stuck in it and then it
was just a wall that then they had a
table and I sat down there and ate my
pancakes in my drink my coffee and
talked to them and got just got her
story but Sweden and San Diego they were
there they weren't out there again super
nice obviously you know I explained to
them that I why what I was interested in
and how I was fascinating I was just you
know so I kind of got into a
conversation with her and she said that
yeah they bit they've they've been here
for a while and they just made a
decision that they wanted to live off
the grid and you know homeschool their
kids and it's a place where you can
freely be yourself
now cherry had a hint of what an accent
like a British accent and I said where
you from
and she said Oregon yeah and I sense
that I shouldn't ask any follow-up
questions because she'd already said
that like you can be anybody you want
there's people who walk around town and
they like and she wants to be slightly
British that's what she wants I could be
wrong maybe she lindsay lohan did that
for a while maybe she did that maybe she
I didn't ask her maybe she grew up in
Oregon then she went to England or so
wherever she got her act I'm at the time
in the desert
might do that to you I don't know give
you a little give you a little flair
it's not like I wanted to press her you
know it's just like okay because that
was the whole point it's like we're out
here we can we can be who we want to be
there's people in town who they get up
every morning and she stands up and she
starts doing the motions of I'm gonna
put a bandana here I'm gonna put a
bandana here I'm gonna paint this side
of my face and I'm gonna put these
bracelets here and I'm a walk around
town this way and you're gonna call me
Trog you know there's people like that
in Slab City who just in every day it's
different bandanas in different places
different names she said it was the same
like that was who he was Truong yeah she
said that the land is owned by it's
three different entities one of which is
the California Teachers Association so
that of course retired teachers can go
there and Snowbird have you heard the
term Snowbird it's when you go out into
I mean I'm being overly specific go out
to the desert in the winter for the
winter months in order in your RV in
order to like but in the summer they get
out of there and she said we can't leave
during the summer because someone will
come and take over our compound and
that's the law of the land you know it's
like nobody owns it yes she wants she
said we want to buy our land a couple of
people have bought their their land like
Salvation Mountain was bought and then
now is being maintained so they stay
through the summer yes and with these
kids she said there's no what we call 90
days of Hell where it's a hundred and
twenty degrees every day and she said
the kids have a pool and I'm looking
around and I don't see a pool so I think
they had like reclaimed it was either
hidden or it was reclaimed or me it was
made out of a dope I'll tell you one
thing those kids are tough because he is
totally like normal kids those kids make
it three yeah because humans are
actually much more capable of
environmental extremes as we've been
talking about then we give ourselves
credit for so I don't know these kids
probably turned out better than our kids
after talking to cherry I felt like I
knew someone on the inside who was a
pillar of the community she was
gonna be about the community and about
how everybody knows everybody and it's
it became much less scary when I
connected with chairing their family you
know Carrie when you connect with cherry
and Trog I'm interested when he comes
into play and then I I never met him so
it's non spoiler alert there's not
something worth spoiling on that I'd
like to skip to your story
but I'll just say we can come back to my
experience leaving their house with a
little more confidence and then I went
in I I went and saw some of the sites
and then had an interesting second night
okay what you know interestingly I will
say that I think that there is a theme
that is emerging here because the theme
of my trip in one sense was you can't
remember something that you don't do you
know and I've been kind of instilling
that in my kids we talked about this in
the book of mythicality a little bit
like I don't remember exactly the words
that we use but essentially you can't
tell a story about something that never
happened you know what you can but it
would be fiction yeah and you find
yourself in different situations and
when you were sitting there trying to
make the decision to either go stay in
this weird RV or not a lot most people
and this is why it costs $30.00 yeah
most people make the decision to not do
that but having made the decision you've
got this experience and you've got this
story it's made your life richer I
assume and that is kind of similar to
what happened to me nod didn't stay in
an RV I so I I wanted to go to a place
where I could have access to hot springs
because that is one of my favorite
things and originally I was gonna go up
all the way to almost Mammoth not yeah
mammoth north of Bishop like five hours
away mm-hmm up in the Sierra Nevada
mountains to a place that piped in hot
springs into like
campsites but it was all taken up and I
do want to do that at some place but at
some point but I had a long list that a
friend recommended like these are places
that I've been that are cool in one of
the places the places that the place
that I chose was this the Sycamore
Mineral Springs Resort and Spa in Avila
Beach which is just north of Pismo I
think I'm saying Avila right yes is
there an H at the beginning it's a V ila
okay and first of all I just swallowed
part of my mustache first of all the
drive up there now if you taste nothing
if you take the five through the middle
of the state it's Bowl ring it's tough
but if you get on the west side of the
state and you take the one and then
there's like another Highway and through
like once you get to Santa Barbara
something cosmic happens like closet I
honestly believe I don't honestly
believe it because I'd not really ended
that kind of thing like yeah I honestly
believe venial II currently believe it
for the sake of this story there is a
feeling that the energy changes which
may or may not be a thing okay like it's
probably just the way that I'm
interacting with my environment and the
way the things changes but like Santa
Barbara is beautiful and then you get
north of Santa Barbara you go up this
mountain road and you drive through this
wine country through these little towns
and it's this it looks like a Bob Ross
painting
it's these that's great so it wasn't
burned because of the fires but I saw
quite a bit of burned areas but I think
I missed the vast majority because
thousands and thousands of acres
hundreds of thousands of acres were
burned so I didn't see that so Santa
Barbara looked great all around it okay
then north of it was these amazing
rolling hills with these pine of these
oak trees kind of sparse oak trees you
know there's this thing that like it
looks like just it's just a grass
covered mountain yes and then there's
just a few trees on it there's just
something like about a little state of
nature that is exactly what I want you
want to say I want to put a house on
anyone sit under that tree right I want
to deface the mountain with
house and sit up there at night and
enjoy my Mountain I know a guy who can
make you one out of pallets good so I
continue but I don't stop there I don't
get out and build a house I go out to
this resort and this is not like a super
nice place this is
I said Resort and Spa but this is a
little bit of a like you're getting up
there closer to Big Sur and you're kind
of in a different way not the desert
sort of hippie you're kind of getting
into like NorCal yeah that part of the
state and you're getting into
it's a hippie sort of situation like to
give you an example
there's no room numbers at this place
okay and what you are seeing things like
cosmic energy yeah like I stayed in a
room called virtue know what I'm saying
listen as long as you can laugh a little
bit at it we just stopped laughing a
little bit then I started cuz they also
had different sweets and the sweets next
to mine were the mythical sweets I
didn't stay in the mythical sweets that
would have been serendipitous but I
didn't I stayed in some other ones and
virtue was my room and it's not a super
nice place like I said I mean it's not
like you're staying at the ritz-carlton
or anything it's like kind of cheesy
decorations inside and you know but it's
got a good energy you know what I'm
saying and they have pumped the water
from the mineral springs the natural hot
mineral springs there and to all these
hot tubs that are on the hillside that
you can come and like rent by the hour
but and they've also put the water into
hot tubs on the balconies balconies but
they'd like the deck the back deck you
had your own individual my own jacuzzi
but it was like a you know it was like a
jacuzzi that you might get from like
Craigslist is kind of what it looked
like like I wasn't like it was made to
look like it was natural it was just
like there's a plastic tub in the back
that's got the water that we use in
there it smells a little bit like sulfur
but that's because it's got the minerals
in it anyway I immediately got into it
naked
yes yeah yeah you were naked before you
drove up right I said under my clothes
and I am that's pretty cool I mean did
you could you see the actual springs
where they were being piped from no okay
couldn't
seek that out okay cuz you know you
don't want to know you may not want to
know the truth yeah there's a lot of
there's a lot of PVC pipe around the
property okay I didn't want to follow
the PVC yeah usually make it I make it
as a rule a personal rule don't follow
the PVC so but I was very happy I was
very pleased I was like this is gonna be
a nice time I'm trying to discover some
things about myself and but I but just a
quick word a quick word about the beach
area there so it's just amazing
community that was this according to the
history of town was this very small like
podunk biker town is the way that it's
described and like when you read about
the history of it and there was some oil
pumping that was happening that was
leaching into the soil and they didn't
know about it but when they discovered
it Exxon discovered that they were
screwing up the environment they were
sued or whatever really and then they
had to end up completely raising the
town and digging down like 15 20 feet to
get rid of all this oil slick raising
the town they because it had leached
into the soil you mean you mean wiping
the town away getting rid of everything
except a few structures bulldozing the
town and then raising little Z dirt and
then Oh raising with this and then
building it back up and now it's like a
cool beach town that is just these
pristine cliffs on both sides and
there's like piers that go out and
there's all these sailboats I mean it
was like one of the most beautiful
places I've seen now they see these cool
beaches are all up and down the coast
but like Pismo Beach is like more
populated and this one was just like
special you know I like hiked up onto
the hill one day and kind of look down
over the beach thought I could have my
house here but that's not it allowed
anyway
the really interesting thing happened to
me the thing that happened to me that
was like I'm gonna make a decision to do
this I I wanted to just stay in my room
they had a restaurant on site that would
do room service I was kind of just
staying in my room and eating things
that were being brought to me I felt
like a king only clothes when someone
came to my room oh you know I'm just
like a naked king I think most kings are
naked
most of the time and 7li have to do
business I don't so I am I go to the
yoga dome because on Saturday morning
they had a yoga class like a hahaha
yogurt I don't know what the word is did
you do you need to drink some water
Oh what ha ha ha ha ha I don't know it's
a type of yoga ok I'm just familiar with
yoga general night [ __ ] specific they
had a dome it was a dome and I walked up
as I'm walking up to the yoga class into
the yoga dome a man about my age it's
coming down and he's like it's pac-man
and I'm like at that moment I was like
imma look I was right on time I was like
I'm gonna walk into a yoga class it's
hard to find his spot I know I'm gonna
be one of the few males in there that's
just how yoga works and and he was
leaving he is in the man he was like I
left my girlfriend in there it's kind of
her thing
oh he's naming and I'm like um I'm gonna
go in there I'm a big man I'm kind of
hard to hide and I go in there and I
look and it's just a sea of women and
there looks to be no spots but they've
spotted me at this point they see me and
I'm like committed you know you froze
like a deer and head like I'm so glad
that I went in that's what you're about
to learn the only space where no one has
put a mat yet and we're talking like 30
to 40 women is there a stage is the
front
oh no so I'm like screw it I'm here
there's one other guy an old guy he
looks to be alone the girls seem to be
in groups of tough types of groups you
know yes yes what I wearing I'm wearing
uh you know just to skin tight spandex
yoga suit no I'm wearing you know a
t-shirt and like dry fit shorts okay you
know you could pick up basketball types
yeah I'm ready for several different
activities okay now they're all wearing
their girl yoga stuff you know tight
pants that kind of thing so I I go to
the front I didn't know if this was like
hippy flowy yoga people and interesting
the
structure talked about that I'll say
that in a second okay I set up my mat in
the front at this point I realize these
women think I'm the instructor you shoot
all right now they probably know I don't
look like the instructor in them in the
look I had on my face when I walked in
the look of the confidence draining
probably didn't say teacher but he go he
went to the teacher he went to the
teacher spot Oh No
so then after I kind of I think I'm
making it clear that I'm not the teacher
when I don't say anything for a like a
30 second period did you face them or
something
no I faced the same direction they're
facing but they're all facing my back
and I'm like kind of sitting there
probably face of getting a little red I
don't know I'm embarrassed easily it's
so so then an older woman could just
feel their eyeballs burning in other
your back like when's he gonna turn out
and instruct us an older woman comes in
oh she wasn't even in the room the
instructor she comes in she has on a
little bit of a flowy thing yes and like
a it's tight underneath but then it's
kind of flowed she's mean she's got like
kind of wildly white hair that she is a
seasoned yoga instructor you could
totally see what she looked like in the
70s you know I'm saying yeah and she
looks at me and she's like it is this
the advanced class what she thought that
I was the instructor for a different
class because she knew that she was
supposed to be there but she was
confused that maybe because I was in the
instructors anyway you were officially
in the but I was off-center I didn't
Center myself I quit and but it's a dome
it's a circle so like they left this
spot and I went just far into the circle
as I could but I was committed at that
point that was okay so that was her I'm
gonna believe the best about this man
and instead of saying sir you're in my
spot this man in a v-neck and dry-fit
Shore's footie sucks must be the
indestructible the advanced class yeah
there's no way I was like there's a but
actually believed that I was like no
because I knew she was thinking about me
she said oh I thought maybe I come into
the wrong class but okay it's just very
crowded or
okay let's get started this woman was a
character and a half that she was like
if you need to cast somebody to be a
yoga instructor in like a movie you know
what I'm saying like she she said we
start and she's like everybody say oh
like she's doing like in but she's kind
of dancing a little bit and she's like
shake your hips like she's really she's
trying to get us all to loosen up mm-hmm
she's she's doing these sort of sexy
moves and getting all the ladies to do
these sexy moves and I'm very glad that
I'm in the front because if I'm in the
back I'm like cuz that way everybody can
see I'm the creep looking at all the
booties moving and you don't wanna be
that guy in the yoga class you know but
in the front I'm like the six foot seven
guy who's obviously has no idea what
he's doing is not comfortable and I'm
like doing the things I'm like gosh why
am I here you were doing him so this she
starts asking people like who is this
who are you guys together like what
groups are these turns out it was two
big groups of women who were
Bachelorette maybe three groups that
were like Bachelorette weekends okay oh
gosh so like girls who are like really
making each other laugh happy to be
together you know the way that goes we
got it we got to put a sash on your head
and take you around to the bars right
but different we kind of different kind
of weekend and and then the old dude who
I don't know who he was with he could
just be a creep but did she ask you you
tall one no she was somebody was like
it's bad bachelorette party or whatever
I was like please don't ask me and I was
like thinking about what I was gonna say
again I was gonna be like I'm alone I
just didn't know weekend of solitude I
didn't have any words that I defined
myself so far I ain't going great I just
been naked this whole time until right
now you know there's nothing that I
could say at that moment that would have
gone over well in the room thankfully
she didn't it was a it was a middle
school please don't call him me teacher
kind of situation yes
okay now she begins to do these chants
and things and I'm participating and of
course my voice is sticking out like a
sore thumb because it's the octave lower
than imagine you
fading in this environment and then she
begins to talk she's got a lot of ideas
that I find questionable you know
metaphysically speaking about the
energies and manifesting flames on top
of our heads and oh she we began to
caress a flame on top of our heads I'm
literally in a group of women caressing
an invisible flame on top of my head
like trying to get the thing to light I
don't know what we were trying to do but
I did it I was there for that then she
breaks out a picture of the Mona Lisa
not making any of this she's gonna do
prop work she's like what do you notice
about this woman this doesn't sound like
yoga and oh it was though man and I was
so happy by the end I got to tell you
and so she holds up a picture of the
Mona Lisa and she's like what do you
notice about this and people are like
answering in the class or whatever and
but she's like the smile you see that
there if some people might call it a
smirk I don't like to use the word smirk
it's a very gentle smile you can do a
lot with that smile for this next
exercise I want Lassalle to make this
expression I once saw a man stand on his
head without his hands for five minutes
simply making this smile headstand she
would make nut makeup she would tell of
these stories of the things that had
happened the supernatural things that
had happened because of the smile the
following things were also said by this
woman during the yoga class I used to
spend time with Tigers three times a day
I wrote all this down because I wanted
to remember were you taking notes during
the yoga class no I took as soon as I
got back here like scrambling for a
minute I got back to my room I got naked
then I started journaling no I used to
spend time with three Tigers three times
a day did she allow I hope there's a
time opening the floor for questions
once you start dropping Tigers I wish I
got a few follow-up questions okay it's
it gets better I used to ride an
elephant and the elephant was happy
turns out she was in the circus guys she
was in the circus but she has a an
apologetic for the circus that makes it
okay that what they did to the animals I
once saw a man put a tiger a horse and
an elephant in the same cage because he
understood their energy
and at what point did you piece together
oh she's a she's a carnie well that's
not a carnie I don't know what she did
at the circus I think she wrote an
elephant well it was happy I'm sure but
she and then the favorite one she said I
was a mime for a while I thought once
you go mime
you stay with these like non sequiturs
it just her spouting off she she would
say things like I was a mine for a while
and I find it helpful to do this with
this move and then she starts doing like
a mime thing I love this woman by the
way I wish I knew her name I can't
remember it I can probably go on the
website and figure out she's one of the
instructors but I actually love this
woman but let me just continue because
then at this point I'm growing more
comfortable with what's happening but
then she says now we're going to do some
partner work you didn't bring a partner
and and so I'm like what what does she
mean by this and then she says okay find
a partner and I immediately make eye
contact with the old man because I'm
like well surely he's my partner
otherwise I'm gonna be just he's zeroed
in on a woman of course he did he's
already part of not with a woman before
he's one of those things where
everyone's getting into their thing I'm
like and I turn around it's saying this
is another middle school experience in
the girl right next to me okay
she's she has looked around trying to
get away from having to be partner with
me she understands what's going on yeah
turns out this girl is the bride
nobody wanted to partner with them right
I got partnered with the bride from the
bachelorette party why why didn't know
why did all of her bachelorettes abandon
her I think they thought you know what
she got one last chance
oh shoot bearded advanced yoga
instructors in here let her have her fun
before she gets married
okay and what we did was not exactly fun
so she begins the instructor begins to
demonstrate what we're about to do it
involved this is what you do with your
partner you stand against back to back
facing away from each other and then you
bend over and your butt's touch and then
you reach through and grab each other's
arms and pull I put my butt up against
this bride's but how tall was she cuz
your butt is high I had to squat a
little bit but there wasn't exactly
great but - but contact she was getting
a little bit low if you know what I mean
it was you know I had to watch myself so
I was trying to she's making it hard for
you yeah probably not the correct making
it difficult to go but - but right and
so we're but - but we leaned down and
I'm grat and I'm grabbing the girl
reaching between your own legs and yeah
I'm grabbing her forearms yeah forearms
and then pulling and you know to her
credit she really took it like a champ
and you know wasn't like I'm trying to
like say things maybe she was a mime
once I'm like trying to you know take
the edge off of the awkwardness a little
bit but she's just going for it and and
something going for it I mean she's like
pulling you know she what's their
conversation I was saying things like
were you from I don't know why it's just
like we're from like you were talking
Sacramento I don't know where they're
from Jose you were both looking through
your legs at each other like we would do
that and then we would get up and I'd
like say something because I felt like I
needed to break the tension a little bit
yeah and then and then she was like I
was like who's getting married she's
like me I was like great congratulations
and then so then then we had to
interlock arms like swing dancers and
dance around in a circle and I don't
know what this yoga is not you got once
you want to deal with freeze your body
then you could do these kinds of things
so now we're going around in a circle
and I'm like I don't know why I said
this but I was like you're having quite
a weekend I just you know because it
that's a bit self agreeing because it
struck me that she's gonna tell this
store this moment you're having with me
right now is making your weekend and
then but then she just said I'm really
hungover so I think they'd had a good
time the night before so she was about
to vomit on you but I you know he was it
was a beautiful experience but the class
closed with she brought out this ball
and she was I want you to hold this ball
and we're going to dance by ourselves
and we're gonna dance like these figures
in this painting right here is another
painting I think she's just picking
random paintings in the room and just
it's coming up with stuff potentially
but she was like you see how this person
is jumping up and kicking their legs out
I want us to do that and she's like the
music I'm going to play is a CD called
yoga chance for women so as if I hadn't
been made to feel a little bit out of
place it was like we're gonna close this
class by dancing to a CD called yoga
chance for women she did look at me like
say I'm sorry I don't have anything for
men I was like okay was that a joke she
was kind of being with her yoga chants
the wrapper for women nope chance the
rapper was not involved by the end of
this class I am jumping up with joy
kicking my legs out I might have hit the
bride I don't know all I know is that at
one point the instructor said he's got
the hang of it she used me as an example
also I was probably very difficult to
not look at so you might as well brought
more attention to it and I I gotta say
though as soon as I quit dancing and she
said class was over I rolled my map up
my mat up and got out of there yeah I
didn't want to have any conversations
with anybody just a beeline for the exit
yeah
yes left the yoga dome went back to my
room stripped off the clothes and began
to journal and wrote this story so
that's where the phrase when in dome
comes from yep exactly you just go with
it but you know what I'm so glad it
happened to me
and I actually went back so emotionally
exhausted having heard that crazy story
I actually went back to the yoga dome
the next day for meditation and
apparently they were doing gentle yoga
leading into meditation and I came in
right when they're starting meditation
and I like interrupted the gentle yoga
class which gentle yoga not as popular
as say yoga because nobody was there was
like three people but I didn't as I
walked in they were all being very
gentle and like wrapping up their class
and she's like giving them aromatherapy
and stuff
my ankles cracked a lot you know and I
walk and I'm like setting Mike stuff up
and like my ankles are cracking a very
self-conscious but I did eventually
settle into a position and you know
remained in silence for half an hour my
time in the yoga's that guided that was
guided my time in the yoga dome was so
worth it not just did you take any
pictures I kind of want to know what the
yoga dome looks like mm-hmm
you're like frolicking and then pulling
out your phone and snapping and snapping
I didn't take a picture of the yogurt oh
yeah you can see what online I didn't
take a picture of cherries house because
I didn't think that was a pro
gawking but I and when I came back after
I wrote this story I wrote some you know
some commentary just about how I was
feeling about how you know obviously I
made this decision to do this and I my
intention in going into the yoga class
was to as part of my weekend I'm trying
to I'm trying to unwind I'm trying to
learn more by myself um but it wasn't
really to go and have the story to tell
I'm glad that I've got the story to tell
it makes it helps with the podcast which
is great but I was like I don't as much
as I am a very purpose-driven kind of
guy and I kind of have goals and that
kind of thing I still don't I don't like
to make decisions to put myself in
situations where I don't feel in control
and I don't know what to do but I need
to do more of that that's why I went
even after my experience that's why I
went back to the yogurt on the next day
I was like I'm gonna go back I'm gonna
who knows what's gonna happen but I'm
kind of kind of embraced this the one
thing that I didn't do that I talked
about potentially doing is going to the
restaurant eating in the restaurant by
myself versus just having it brought to
my room
most anyone put my clothes on but also I
was like I don't I'm not I'm ready for
that level of you know exposure in a
similar way I on the second night I'm
skipping ahead did not decide to go into
town even though after having dinner
with cherry able all five of their kids
and my neighbor Liz but not the Swedish
woman she was gone they were eventually
going into town and I said I might see
you there
and I thought there was a chance that I
would go but then I didn't but I I did
take many huge steps like you're saying
to just put yourself out there and say
you know what I'm gonna I'm gonna
physically leave my comfort zone and and
try to be open to self-reflection and I
mean it sounds cheesy but it it is
really what I think we were both trying
to do which is like a level of
self-discovery you know I was I was
reading about how your personality or at
least aspects of your personality are
and now this is this was me reading
while I was there during that day my
first full day there after breakfast I
went I went back to the well I saw some
sights which I can tell you about but at
one point I went back to the RV and I
was reading about how you know what one
up one way to understand personality is
that when you're when you're young it's
a it's a way to you build your
personality in order to protect yourself
and survive right and then as you get
older and you may not need these certain
protective layers and techniques for how
you engage with the world in order to
convince yourself that you're going to
be able to develop and make it
physically there's certain aspects of
your personality you've built that then
are
are not arguably necessary and become a
become a shell and a protective layer
that you don't need anymore I know that
you could live your life without that
that's just one that's one way to look
at aspects of your personality which may
have negative impacts on you that you
can begin to dismantle right mm-hmm so I
was thinking about these things and you
know that was kind of something that I
was reflecting on it trying to put
myself in a position to say okay I've
got I've got time I've got silence where
I can think about my true self and what
AM what am i adding what what are in
what ways is our is fear in a general
sense driving the the way that I act and
the thing the decisions I make and the
decisions the things that I don't do you
know so as an example like not you not
going to the restaurant or me not going
into town might for us have represented
you know being fearful or the things
that we did do like you go in into the
dome even though the guy said turn back
while you still have a chance right he
almost got me to not go you know making
a decision yeah you know what I'm gonna
I'm gonna learn something from this
experience and not run from it even
though I may fear embarrassment by
putting on a Mona Lisa smile and a
jack-and-jill frolic or whatever
whatever he was getting you to emulate I
I would say that was a theme of of my
self-reflection and I'll come back to
that but so when I the next morning when
I when I left the camp freedom compound
I drove back around to Salvation
Mountain which in the 70s there was a
guy who had like he found Jesus okay and
then he did he got so excited that he
decided to go out to this very spot in
the desert on this like big sand berm
and start painting it mm-hmm like with
Adobe cement and ultimately a crap-ton
of latex paint and this guy lived out of
his truck squatting in the desert around
slab city where where there was a
community and he started painting like
God loves you Bible verses all this
stuff on a Salvation Mountain that you
may have seen in like a Coldplay video
or a Ke$ha video right among among
others and it's my RV was just across
the street from it so there there are
people driving in and parking and seeing
this thing there's no admission you can
walk on it and you can walk on it and
it's the only places that they say to
walk on it it's like a yellow brick road
that goes around the that goes across
the whole thing and I can I can show you
a picture here so you can look at it
it's it's three stories tall my selfie
game is a little off if you go to if you
go to the here you can flip that so you
see it says god is love at the top of
the mountain it's basically three
stories tall and you can meander and I'm
taking Jade on her leash and light were
meandering and like you feel like you
can you're gonna fall off at any moment
but it's like slick undulating latex
paint like layers and layers and layers
of it and it's absolute it it looks like
the craziest putt-putt course
installation that you would ever that
you would ever see without the pup-pup
part and you can climb all the way to
the top of it and it's just crazy so
like I did that I'm not talking anybody
even though there's people around and
then like next to it there's this thing
called the Hogan which I might be a
Native American term it's also the last
name of an awesome wrestler but this
other hill over here that looks like
another painted latex hill you can see
that it has windows in it well this is
not he didn't paint the hill he built a
huge dome made out of hay bales and
Adobe and there's like you can
when you walk inside of it it's held up
by these trees it's crazy it was like I
was walking around in another world
which just felt awesome in it but it's
weird because there's this constant
self-consciousness of like I don't
belong here there's people who live here
and they know I'm just kind of walking
through I feel like I'm stepping on
their toes and like who's this hipster
guy walking around you know so there's
this constant self-awareness that I had
to continue to check in order to run in
enjoy myself and on the other hand to
like I don't know to feel like kind of
break through and I have a delusion emit
experience right does that make sense
yeah and then I Drive into slab city to
the other side of town and there's an
area called East Jesus which has no
actually has no religious connotation at
all that's it just east of Salvation
Mountain that's not what it is
it well in reading the Wikipedia East
Jesus just means it's like two clicks
left of nowhere
it's basically what it means it's like
it's like a way of saying the middle of
nowhere people say oh I said East Jesus
it's like you'll never find it it might
even seem anti Jesus or something I
don't know is where the origin of the
saint but when you get there there's a
there's like a Cessna that's turned on
its side that's now become a it's just
like an art piece and there's all this
reclaimed crap like cars and stuff that
are turned into sculptures oh yeah and
you walk around I mean if you walk
around in the courtyard and it's like
freaky like freaky baby dolls and I mean
I'll show you the pictures but it's it
feels it's an interesting feeling to be
walking around in such a creepy place
baking in the desert all by yourself you
know when you're not talking anybody
except your dog there were two dads with
their kids that were there for a little
bit of it I kind of wanted him to leave
because it was he was screwing with my
experience kids and then there was a
like a cordoned off area on the edge of
it where there was like all
these old abandoned RVs and like a tour
bus that was half buried and coming out
of the desert and people would live
there but I think they had all left
because it was too hot but it was yeah
he was getting too hot getting really
hot it got so hot that after that I
drove through slab city and there's like
it's a grid of what looks to be RVs some
a few new but most all of them look
abandoned and to the point where people
put signs out and say do not enter so
because people think they can just take
over but people are actually living in
them there's people walking around I
didn't really talk to anybody I just
kind of cruise walked are you drunk
I drove through with my a/c pumping it
was like really hot to me like nine is
anybody else you drive through not
really there's a few people who drive
around they'll go to East Jesus and then
leave but I was like driving up and down
the rows and like looking at people like
the people some people would wave and
like you know they've just chosen as a
way of life to to live here off the grid
it's like a simple life though they like
bring in huge containers of water and
then they'll make runs an hour away to
the Walmart or something once a month
and then just live out there people
riding around on bike there's anybody
selling anything are they making any
money
are they just living off of there was
one guy who who had just set up shop out
of his van like selling trinkets but I
think that's more for tourists like
closer to Salvation Mountain so not
really a lot of that like the range is
the name of that like outdoor bar area
but they don't sell drinks you have to
bring your own drinks if you go do it up
going there I did not I went back to the
RV and like it got so hot I couldn't be
out and I didn't want to have Jade out
in the heat I didn't think she was used
to it but the urge it when you're in the
RV or just in shade I'm in shade and
there's a little breeze and that was all
I could ask for and then that that night
I went to eat dinner with cherry and
Abel and the family and then that was
great and then on the way back on the
way to my RV
took a little detour to the hot springs
that is out there and this hot springs
was like the most legit hot springs the
way you imagined it like it was
literally a water hole in the middle of
a desert and it was her palm trees
around it no some smaller brush trees
and it was I'd say about 30 feet across
and there was it was cloudy water and
just like mud walls and it was bubbling
up in the middle and there were two old
naked men putting on their clothes and
saying all right I'll see you donut the
rain just missed it just missed him and
then I so then nobody was there I got
the Sun was going down oh no I got naked
and I and I walked down a wooden ladder
into it and it was it could have 96 to
98 degrees I mean it was it was hot well
too cooler than your hot tub that's how
much I would put mine on for but like
104 is like this hot as you can get your
own yeah yeah wasn't that hot it was
almost that hot I was surprised with how
hot it was because sometimes the hot
springs will be hotter than you know the
regulations I didn't know that but I
knew that the guys had gotten out so I
and they said get in it so yeah there
are some that are hotter than like
there's something you can't get in like
one there's one that's like 170 degrees
oh gosh yeah you can't get in where that
comes out you can get in down straight
and when it's cooled down but it was it
was over my head like and I was I was
alone I was I wasn't I think you might
would have done it but I I did not swim
down and try to touch the bottom at
where he was bubbling up hmm I didn't
want to do that yeah Jade with Jade is
on the banks and she was like looking at
me like what the heck why you getting
naked and what are you doing jumping in
this water she thought I was nuts but
that that was like a that was like a
surreal moment I took like a mental
picture cuz I'm like once she walked
over it the slopes
to come up and you can be in the water
like up to your waist and ultimately
your ankles and you can get out of other
way but like I'm standing there and the
Sun set and it's like across the desert
and there's nobody there it was it's how
you imagine you want to do like a the
most rustic a pleaser but nobody was
there that's at that point yeah it was
crazy I mean no it no one will be there
during the day cuz it's so freakin high
then I went back to the RV and I was you
know and I and um just hung out by
myself did some reading and then end up
talking to the neighbor like she was she
was outside on her phone and she was
like I couldn't see her because she was
around the corner she was like blink and
I was like yeah she was like if I'm
talking too loud just let me know I'm
like no it's fine and then she got off
the phone and I ended up going over
there and sitting down with her
and just hanging out instead of going
into town and like we were having a
conversation and I forgotten that about
the psychic sign oh she had the psychic
sign yes she was the one with the
psychic sign and and so we were looking
at Salvation Mountain and I was like and
she I had heard her on the phone talking
about how she had used tarot cards to
determine where she was going to live
and I said and I was like you know a
sparking conversation I was like do you
think that that guy who on a mission
from God painted that hill over there
and the the universe as you refer to it
the speaking to you through these cards
to tell you where to live you think it's
the same thing and like she started you
know it's I my point is not to get into
her answer or the or the philosophy of
it all but just to say that that's the
that's the nature of the conversation
and I think I might have inadvertently
had a condescending tone when talking
about her tarot cards because I'm like
I'm asking detailed questions like well
if you use the cards to tell where you
were gonna live did you and you ended up
in San Diego
what did you say anywhere on earth the
cards please tell me or did you say San
Diego because I kind of want to go there
in a couple
the places and this is in retrospect
because graciously I mean she was she
was very kind friendly person but at one
point the conversation turned and she
was like I don't know if I should say
this but I feel and I so I'm taking a
risk in oh and it's dark and she's we're
not sitting next to each other she's
like sitting eight feet away from me and
I can't see your face because of the way
that the moonlight and the shadows of
her trailer
I felt like I was in the light of the
the moonlight but she was in the shadow
so it was like it was kind of creepy I
couldn't see her face at all I could you
see this her silhouette and and then
she's she's like she starts as she said
you know it maybe it could be and I
don't remember exactly what she said but
she kind of described what she what
might be someone's mental but where
someone might be coming from from a
place of fear when having the type of
conversation that I was having with her
and it was like weird it's like it kind
of freaked me out and I was like did you
just did you just like give me a reading
or something and she was like I'm sorry
I shouldn't do that and it was like she
had described it was just weird because
it freaked me out a little bit when she
was talking about when people you know I
think you're speaking from a place of
fear when you're having this
conversation with me about these things
that my practices do responding and I
was like I the way I responded was did
you just like give me a reading or
something and then I made a joke about
how I didn't have five dollars so I
deflected which you know she ended up
saying well I'm an I'm an empath I can
tell and I legitimately felt like that
she picked that she did have she had
insight into how
like the psychology of how I was feeling
but I too clarified it I didn't think it
was spiritual or I didn't think it was
negative in nature or even spiritual in
nature my interpretation of it looking
back on it was that like in the way that
you would like have a conversation with
a therapist he would have insight into
like okay you're kind of hiding behind
your fear here in the way that you're
asking me these type of questions does
that make sense that's ultimately how I
felt like she was talking to me she
could tell that you were specular
speculative and you're in the nature of
your questions yeah not speculative
that's not the right word the right word
is a suspicious yeah yeah so but it was
kind of a weird moment and I think she
you know we we kept talking and I think
she was like she wasn't gonna offer like
give me a palm reading or whatever it is
she was she was had her sign up for but
she gave me the opportunity to ask for
that but in the moonlight and in the you
know I had reached I had reached I'd
reached my level of comfort I'd reached
the limit of that and I was like you
know what I think I'm gonna turn in I'm
going to bed so it kind of had this it
didn't end abruptly but I kind of had
this I don't know it was kind of a weird
vibe kind of a moment that's like I
didn't know you see you the next day I
saw her the next day
and I was like I was packing my stuff up
and I was leaving and I was like you
know I appreciated our conversation last
night and I wanted to apologize if I
felt condescending if anything I said
seemed condescending and she was like no
I think whenever people speak from a
place of fear it's all it's always if
you understand it it's always
understandable
like if I were to understand what it is
you're afraid of I would I would not
hold it against you it's just we didn't
discuss it it's kind of what she meant
does that make sense yeah I guess
I guess somebody who's out in the desert
with a sign and finding themselves they
can talk like they can say these type of
things you're like I know the mode that
you go into with those kinds of
questions so I could see what she would
take offense at it
I didn't mean to well but I good like
what you like what was underneath your
but also there was this level of fear
that I had about being in the whole
place is like what am I like I said
audibly a few times I was like what am I
doing here like after the conversation
with her I went back and I went back and
I went to bed and I'm like in the bed
and I'm like trying to go to sleep and
I'm like I I heard I could hear her
footsteps she's sneaking and I just felt
like they were coming around my trailer
gonna kill you and there was the auditor
there was a little scratchy scratch on
the door and Jade like perked up in the
bed but Jade didn't bark and then in the
morning I felt I talked to her I felt
fine and I don't think she was creeping
around my trailer anything else
significant happen it's not like there's
a it's like you spend quality time with
yourself you isolate yourself with
yourself and you you learn a little bit
well I can't say exactly what I learned
but it's funny because it's tough you
talk about personality stuff as stuff
that I'm kind of exploring within myself
and I think that I I don't mean to cut
you off again that's the part I left out
is like I think that's why it kind of
freaked me out was because she talked
about fears and that was me and that was
the thing that I was had been thinking
about and that I'd kind of walked around
I was good I was uneasy being there so
there were a couple of different levels
of fear that I had that I think anyone
not anyone could pick up on but someone
who you know you know it doesn't have to
be creepy in order to pick up on it but
it but it freaked me out a little bit
I'm I'm processing some of the same
stuff that was one of the reasons to run
away now I also kind of knew that a
couple of days is not enough time to
actually make any real progress
just people that I know that have done
like right the time alone that you got
you need a few days before you'd like to
have some kind of breakthrough I mean
the main thing I learned what besides
how to have an awesome yoga class with
with a lot of Bachelorette women is I'm
not very good at being alone like as
much as I want to be alone and I'm an
introvert through and through and I say
things like I need my alone time
I find when I am finally in that place
where I'm alone I'm kind of like I'm not
that good at this and there is this
slightly complicating factor of somebody
might know who I am it's like you know I
like I went to the spa got a massage and
then went into the the hot I was like
interacting with his girl and like she
was like you this is where you can go to
there's a other another hot tub like on
the hillside that I went to for like 30
minutes cuz it comes with the massage or
whatever and then I like come back down
the hill on my paying she's like by the
way I'm a big fan of your show and
because that happens pretty regularly
thankfully great that means people are
watching I that's why I didn't go to the
restaurant by myself
right because I'm yeah their
self-consciousness there's this like ooh
Rhett's eating alone what's he's weird
I'm gonna go tell my friends you know
they got from the show that mythical
morning thing like he eats alone at
restaurants he's a creep you know like
even though I know that it's not
actually what that means I have I have
fears associated with that and so
there's a lot of self-consciousness as
I'm kind of going about my alone weekend
that's why ideally I would just go to
the desert where I'm completely alone
and I actually don't have to interact
with people and I'm like I'm forced to
kind of confront things within myself
which is what I hope to do later yeah
all that to say I end up doing things
like I'm not gonna watch any TV but then
I watch TV I'm gonna watch a movie but I
bring up a movie on my you know I'm
saying it's like I don't actually
completely can disconnect I kind of feel
like the lesson I learned is I need to
set boundaries and rules going in and
actually follow through with them but
even getting I mean if getting in touch
with yourself as first getting in touch
with your self-consciousness
you know I think that is an element of
what it sounds like we both did
a little bit but I did but I confronted
it head-on in that yoga class and I was
dancing but I was dancing at the end you
know okay well this has been a fun
catch-up conversation this has been
quite quite a weekend for you huh why do
we good huh
for you you're gonna tell this story
right you're telling this story right
now about the big guy that you touched
his butt with your butt right before you
got married you'll tell your husband
about it right that was crazy
all right shout out to all my slab errs
in Slab City and we'll talk at you next
week with another one you know thanks
for hanging out
[Music]